when you  face some type of adversity or challenge  where your your identity is shifted and  rocked  it is a scary time because i had to look  at every fear  swear to god for the next three years of  my life matthew for that i faced i  looked at every fear i wrote them all  down on the list my biggest fears and i  just said  these things have power and control over  me and i need to become like batman and  live in a cage with all these fears and  until i can stand up and see all my  fears around me and be able to stand up  with power with command and not be  afraid of all the fear not be afraid of  the bats hitting my face but actually  embrace the bats  and take it all on and that's what i did  for the next three to five years i wrote  down a list of my biggest fears i did  them all one by one and it was miserable